the people of Volus say they've never
seen anything like it cars washed out to
sea roads in and out of the city severed
by torrents and streets impassable with
mud
the fire service has told residents to
stay indoors because rain may have
undermined roads that appear to be safe
Volos is now without electricity without
telecommunications without fresh water
the roof fell in from the rain that
damage is huge they should help us I
have a family and kids how are we going
to sleep last night we slept here and
there it's unbelievable
residents in Volo say they've been
unable to find local government
officials Municipal resources seem
overwhelmed
the city of Wallace is living a tragedy
this was the epicenter of the storm no
one has seen anything like it before
Volos received half a Year's worth of
rain in just two days sudden rainfall
has historically caused flooding in
Greece and it's left the scars of dry
torrent Birds throughout the landscape
over the Millennia but experts now speak
of unprecedented volumes of water
that also means unprecedented volumes of
mud and debris carried Downstream
I'm 44 years old and I've never seen
something like this we know that in
Pelion in Zagora there is a lot of
rainfall but this was unprecedented it's
never happened before the damage was
caused by the river the torrent
it's Greece's second natural disaster in
a few weeks during The Heat Of Summer a
hundred and fifty thousand hectares of
forest and farmland were burnt by
wildfires the country is counting the
cost of the power of nature once again
John saropoulos Al Jazeera La Mia
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera